after the rocky launch of no man's sky
hello games all but fell off the radar
now they're back with the long-awaited
foundation update to be here to tuck
into the foundation update introduces
base building to the game and serves as
a quilt foundation for things to come as
the name implies in a post on their
website hello games explained that this
marks the first of many free patches for
no man's sky the update also adds three
new game modes featuring different rule
sets normal mode which is what you're
used to from the first iteration
creative mode which lets you explore the
universe without limits and build a huge
base and survival mode which is a more
challenging endurance experience face
building will enable you to create an
outpost using modular structures and
decorations made using resources you
find while exploring the game world
you'll also be able to recruit alien
life-forms to help research new tech use
terminus teleporters in space stations
to get to and from your base with ease
expand your base with storage containers
to stockpile resources and dismantle
your previous homestead to refund all
your resources the update will allow you
to farm purchase and customize
freighters to transfer resources
discover new resource types and craft
new items there are also visual upgrades
like motion blur temporal anti-aliasing
and new UI indicators including better
representations of shield and life
support changes there's also now a photo
mode on ps4 no man's sky creator Sean
Murray has tweeted if you could have
lived our lives over the last month's
you'd know how meaningful this is check
out our story on site for the full patch
notes and let me know what you think of
the changes in that comment section for
everything else that matters in gaming
stay tuned to gamespot